ORDER OF THE ASSEMBLY
TRANSPORTATION [inaudible]
AUTHORITY.
GOING FORWARD --
MAN SOME PEOPLE PLEASE ESTABLISH
A QUORUM [inaudible]
FRAZIER.
HERE FONG HERE AGUIAR-CURRY
[inaudible]
BAKER [inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
CHIU [inaudible]
DALY THEIR FRIEDMAN.
GIPSON THERE HARPER PRESENT
MATHIS [inaudible]
MEDINA [inaudible]
NAZARIAN [inaudible]
O'DONNELL.
SO WE HAVE A QUORUM WE'RE GONNA
GO ON TO ANNOUNCEMENTS MEASURES
OFF FILE FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR
S. YOUR ONE THIRTY THREE FILE
ITEM FIVE SCR.
ONE FIFTY NINE AND FILE ITEM
NINE SP SEVENTY SIX HAVE BEEN
PULLED BY THE COMMITTEE. TO
REMOVE ONTO MEASURES ON CONSENT
[inaudible]
WE HAVE.
FILE ITEM NUMBER.
THREE S. C. R. ONE ELEVEN FILE
ITEM NUMBER SIX AS J. R..
THIRTY WE MEMBERS LIKE TO REMOVE
AN ITEM FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR [inaudible]
DRIVEN MOTION.
HAVE MOTION BY MISTER GIPSON
SECOND BY A YEAR CURRY.
OF MEN CERTAINLY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL FOR THE CONSENT CALENDAR ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE FONG FONG AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I A BAKER
[inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
CHIU [inaudible]
DALY.
DALY AYE FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE HARPER.
HARPER AYE MATHIS MATHIS AYE
MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE NAZARIAN [inaudible]
O'DONNELL.
IT HAS NINE LEAD ROLE
CONTRAPTION MEMBERS WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON TO ACR TWO SIXTY THREE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER REVERSE.
PLEASE PROCEED WITH ALREADY
THINK IMMIGRANT PARENTS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ACR TWO SIX
THREE WOULD DEDICATE THE
INTERCHANGE BETWEEN.
STATE HIGHWAY TO TEN AND
INTERSTATE FIVE IN LA COUNTY AS
THE CALTRANS DISTRICT SEVEN
FOLLOWING WORKERS MEMORIAL.
INTERCHANGE THE MEN AND WOMEN
WHO BUILD AND MAINTAIN OUR
HIGHWAYS FACE CONSIDERABLE RISK
ON A DAILY BASIS ON THIS BILL
PAYS TRIBUTE TO THE RISK AND
THEIR SACRIFICES.
THE MOST RECENT VICTIM FROM MY
DISTRICT MISTER HOT HEADED
OFFICE WAS A CALTRANS
ELECTRICIAN ON THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION FOUNDATION HAS
COMMITTED TO RAISING ALL FUNDS
NECESSARY --
FOR THE SIGNS I RESPECTFULLY
RESTS REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU MOVE THE BILL.
SO WE DO IT WE DO HAVE FIRST
SECOND OR THIRD NO FOURTH.
A THINK OF ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC THAT SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THIS RESOLUTION.
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
THE NUMBERS.
PER RESOLUTION SAYING NON
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS OF THE AUTHOR.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TIME
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR LIBEL.
WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR OUR DEDICATION TO THE PHONE
CALTRANS WORKERS WE REALLY DO
APPRECIATE IT.
AND WITH THAT MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS BE ADOPTED.
WE HAVE FIRST BY MR MATHESON
SECOND BY MISTER GETS.
THE MOTION IS BE ADOPTED TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE FONG FONG AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BAKER
[inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible] TO DALY.
DALY AYE FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN AYE
GIPSON ARE GIPSON AYE HARPER.
HARPER AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS AYE MEDINA.
MEDINA INEZ ARYAN [inaudible]
O'DONNELL.
IT HAS NINE WE'VE ROLE OPEN --
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
CONGRATULATIONS THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
MISTER SALAS AC OR TWO SEVENTY
SIX PLEASE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS PRESENT BEFORE
YOU ACR TWO SEVENTY SIX FIRST
LET ME EXCEPT THE COMMITTEES --
LISTED AMENDMENTS IN THE
ANALYSIS.
I'VE THIS RESOLUTION WOULD
DESIGNATE STATE ROUTE TOOL FOR
BETWEEN STATE HIGHWAY FIFTY
EIGHT JUST SAY RAY ROUTE.
ONE SEVENTY EIGHT AS A HARVEY L.
HALL MEMORIAL HIGH.
HIGHWAY HARVEY HOLES PERSONAL
FRIEND IS A LOCAL BUSINESSMAN
THINK THIS IS GONNA BE SOMETHING
GREAT FOR THAT COMMUNITY.
HARVEY ALWAYS HAD A SAYING UNITY
IN THE COMMUNITY AND THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO HERE BY
ESTABLISHING THIS MEMORIAL
HIGHWAY.
THANK YOU MISTER IS ALSO ANY
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THAT
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OUR SUPPORT OF
THE AUTHORS RESOLUTION.
SEEING NONE ANY MEMBERS THE
PUBLIC THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION.
OTHER AUTHORS RESOLUTION.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MISTER
FUNG.
I THINK IT'S CHAIR ALAN I THINK
IT'S ON THEM --
WHEN THEY GET SOME MEMBER SALAS
FOR BRINGING THIS MEASURE
FORWARD TO HONOR THE MEMORY OF
BASS A MAYOR IVY HALL NEKTONIC
LOCAL PUBLIC OFFICIAL?
AND PLEASE LET MYSELF AND
SANDERS FULLER AND BY TACKLE BE
ADDED AS JOINT AND PRINCIPAL
AUTHORS OF ACR.
TWO THREE SIX PAYROLL AS THEM
HAS AS AS WAS OUR SALAS MENTION
WAS KNOWN FOR BRINGING PEOPLE
TOGETHER IN THE SPIRIT UNITY
ALLEY AS HARVEY HALL SERVE THE
CITY OF BAKERSFIELD.
BUT HE SAVED MANY LIVES BY
FOUNDING HALL AND THAT SERVICE.
MAYOR BECAUSE MORE THAN WORTHY
OF HIS AS A NATION ARE
COMMITTING ASPECT WE ASKED IVA.
ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE HAVE QUESTIONS OF THE
AUTHOR.
SEEING NONE MISTER CELLS WHICH
LIKE CLOSE.
BUT APPRECIATE DRIVE VOTED
HONORING --
GREAT ICON IN OUR COMMUNITY LIKE
I SAID HE'S HIS WHOLE HASH TAG
IF WE HAD TO DO HASHTAG WAS
UNITY IN THE COMMUNITY AND
BRINGING PEOPLE TOGETHER.
GREAT MANA GREAT FRIEND SOMEONE
I GOT TO CITY COUNCIL WHEN I WAS
A CITY COUNCIL MEMBER AND
APPRECIATE TRIBAL.
THANK YOU MISTER SOSA LOOK FOR
THAT HASH TAG ON YOUR FACEBOOK.
I'M.
AND I UNDERSTAND WE ARE MANY THE
RESOLUTION I APPRECIATE YOU
ADDING THE CO AUTHORS AND HE
AMENDMENTS.
SUPPORT AT ALL NAMING
RESOLUTIONS COMPLY WITH THE
COMMITTEE'S POLICY.
AS THE POLICIES IN PLACE TO
PROTECT THE STATE THE MEMBERS OF
THE LEGISLATURE ALSO.
WITH THE AMENDMENTS HOUSE WHEN
YOU'RE RESOLUTION TODAY BAD
SECRETARY WE HAVE A FIRST WITH A
YEAR CURRY A SECOND WITH MR
MATHIS.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS BE ADOPTED WITH
AMENDMENTS FRAZIER.
FRAZIER I FONG FONG AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
BAKER [inaudible]
BERMAN.
CHU.
CHU AYE DALY.
DALY AYE FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE HARPER.
HARPER AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS I MEDINA.
MEDINA INEZ ARYAN [inaudible]
O'DONNELL [inaudible]
O'DONNELL I THANK YOU.
THAT IS A LITTLE LEAD ROLE
CONTRAPTION MEMBERS --
MISTER TING.
AB.
EIGHTY SEVEN SEED WHEN YOU'RE
READY SIR [inaudible]
THANK YOU CHAIR.
FIRST LET ME THINK THANK YOU FOR
JOINING ON TO THIS BILL THE
JOINT AUTHORED VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THAT.
PA AB EIGHTY SEVEN GIVES LAW
ENFORCEMENT THE AUTHORITY TO
IMPOUND AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES
OPERATING WITHOUT A VALID PERMIT
ON PUBLIC ROADS.
AND HOLD ON TO THAT VEHICLE
UNTIL A VALID PERMIT IS IN PLACE --
THIS BILL STEMMED ORIGINALLY
FROM AND AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES
THAT POINT WAS OCCUPIED BY A
HUMAN BEING --
BUT THE PUT AND VIA COMPANY PUT
A VEHICLE ON THE ROAD --
WITHOUT A PROPER PERMIT
UNFORTUNATE THAT POINT OUR MAYOR
IN OUR POLICE CHIEF WERE NOT
ABLE TO GET OFF THE ROAD --
VERY MUCH WE APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT.
IT CHAIR MEMBERS JONATHAN FELT
OF THE CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION WE THINK THIS BILL
CLARIFIES OUR AUTHORITY AND
APPRECIATE THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FOR HIS EFFORTS ON THIS.
ONE I THINK IT MAKES EXPENSE.
CAPTURING CHAIR MEMBERS LARA BUT
IT'S HAPPENED THAT WE ARE
THINKING AUTHOR FOR WORKING WITH
US IN OUR CONCERNS IN THE
ORIGINAL DRAFT AYE WE TO THINK
IT'S CLARIFY THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
HAVE THE ABILITY TO REMOVE
VEHICLE THAT DO NOT HAVE A VALID
PERMITS.
AND ALSO PROVIDES FOR SCENARIOS
TO I GET THOSE BECAUSE RELEASED.
MARGARET BUT YOU DON'T HAVE A
GLOBAL AUTOMAKERS I CONCUR WITH
PREVIOUS TESTIMONY AND THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR AND HIS STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH US.
RESOLVER CONCERTS THANK YOU FOR
THAT ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO LIKE TO SPEAK IN.
SUPPORT OF THE AUTHORS BILL.
SEEING NONE ANY MEMBERS THE
PUBLIC FEEL LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THE AUTHORS BILL.
SEEING NONE QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE OF THE AUTHOR.
CERTAINLY LIKE CLOSE I JUST
RESPECT FAST.
FIVE THANK YOU MISS DOING WE
HAVE THE FIRST BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GIPSON SECOND BY SIMPLY NEVER
CHIU.
I WANT TO THANK YOU --
MISCANTHUS BILL NOT TAUGHT AS A
THOMAS VEHICLES BEGIN TO TEST ON
PUBLIC ROADS.
WILL BECOME INCREASINGLY
IMPORTANT MAKE SURE LAW
ENFORCEMENT DO NOT HAVE TO WAIT
FOR DMV TO ACT IN ORDER TO
REMOVE THESE VEHICLES IF THEY
HAVE NOT BEEN PROPERLY PERMITTED.
I APPRECIATE YOUR JUST PASSION
TO KEEP THIS THING GOING AND
HAPPY TO JOIN AUTHOR THE BILL
WITH YOU --
AND MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
THE MOTION.
IS THAT THE SENATE AMENDMENTS BE
CONCURRENT FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE FONG FONG AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BAKER
[inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
CHAU.
CHIU I DALY.
DALY AYE FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE HARPER HARPER AYE
MATHIS.
MATHIS I MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE NAZARIAN [inaudible]
O'DONNELL [inaudible]
O'DONNELL I YOUR ELEVEN VOTES
WILL KEEP THE ROLE CONTRACTS
MEMBERS GRADUATION ERA THINKING
THANK YOU.
SO WE HAVE A LETTER THAT US FROM
THE MEMBER.
QUIRK SILVA.
I HAVE STAFF MEMBER PRESENT IN
HER PLACE SO WITH THEM EVER COME
FORWARD FOR QUITE SOME OF AB.
FIVE FIVE EIGHT MEMBERS THAT MAY
WE DO HAVE A LETTER ON FILE.
FOR THE REQUEST.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO PRESENT ON BEHALF OF
SHARON QUIRK SILVA.
MINES MATTHEW HURLEY I'M THE
STAFFER FOR THE THE BILL.
EIGHTY FIVE FIVE EIGHT AB FIVE
FIVE EIGHT SIMPLY REQUIRES THE
AIR RESOURCES BOARD TO DEVELOP A
SUMMARY ON THE PRODUCTION
REGISTRATION A FLEXIBLE FUEL
VEHICLES AND E. EIGHTY FIVE LOW
CARBON FUEL. TO MAKE THAT SOME
REPUBLIC PROVIDED TO BEGIN EPA
AND THEN TO DIVIDE ELOP
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR POLICY BASED
ON SUCH A REPORT.
FLEXIBLE FUEL VEHICLES ARE OFT
OVERLOOKED COMPONENT FOR
REDUCING THE LARGEST PRODUCERS
OF GREENHOUSE GASES IN OUR STATE --
INTENTION THIS BILL IS TO MAKE
SURE THE CALIFORNIA HAS EVERY
POTENTIAL TOOL AVAILABLE TO US.
AND REGION ARE AMBITIOUS
CHRONICLES.
IT IS ENJOY BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
RECEIVE NO NO VOTES IN THE
SENATE AND I HAVE WITH ME AT TO
BUT WITNESSES TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT
HAVE AND I WILL.
PRESENT UNANIMOUS REPRESENTING
PLEASE.
KATHY VAN AUSTIN REPRESENTING
PEARSON FUELS IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL.
JOIN ME TO TEST FIRE.
LEAVE IT ON THAT OR THAT WE GOT.
SUPPORT YES.
ENCOURAGE YOUR STRONG SUPPORT.
GRAMM NOISE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
THE LOW CARBON FUELS COALITION
STRONG SUPPORT.
APPRECIATE THAT ANY OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
OF THE AUTHORS BILL.
SEEING NONE.
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THAT
WOULD LIKE.
TO THAT'S FINE OPPOSITION TO THE
AUTHORS BILL.
THING NINE ANY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE HAVE OUR QUESTIONS OF
THE AUTHOR [inaudible]
LIKE CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME AND CONSIDERATION AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR SO WE HAVE A
FIRST BY.
MISTER CHU AND A SECOND BY
MISTER O'DONNELL --
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR UP BRING
THE BILL FORWARD.
WE'VE OPPORTUNITY ENCOURAGE
THOSE WHO OWN FLEXIBLE FUEL VIEW
VEHICLES USE E..
EIGHTY FIVE I FEEL THAT IS A
LOWER GHG IMPACT COMPARED
GASOLINE.
YOUR BILL WILL ALLOW FOR MORE
INFORMATION --
TO BETTER OCCURS THOSE EFFORTS
AND WITH THAT I'LL BE AYE.
ADDING MY VOTE UMAP SECRETARY
PLEASE KALRA.
THE MOTION IS THAT THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS BE CONCURRENT AND
FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE FONG.
FONG NOT LETTING AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I BAKER
[inaudible]
BERMAN.
CHU.
CHU AYE DALY.
DALY AYE FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE HARPER.
HARPER AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS I MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE NAZARIAN.
O'DONNELL O'DONNELL AYE.
THAT IS TENANTS OUT WILL LOOK AT
THE ROLE PERHAPS MEMBERS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
ACCOUNTABLE IS ON THE NUMBERS
HOPE YOUR MEMBER GETS BETTER
SOON.
SO WE CAN MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM
TEN SP FIVE OH TO MISTER
PORTANTINO.
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
BEING PROMPT TODAY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS --
TODAY I'M BACK TO PRESENT S. B.
FIVE VOTE [inaudible]
TO WHICH GOD LOVE YOU.
YOU'RE GOOD BILL.
THANK TYPES.
I'LL JUST SHUT UP GIVE EXPERT
TESTIMONY WOULD LIKE TO PRESENT
THE SENATE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BURRS
THERE'S TO PROVISIONS IN S. B.
FIVE WILL TWO ONE OF WHICH IS
ALREADY BEEN HEARDAPPROVED BY
THIS COMMITTEE.
REGARDING A D. EAST OF THE
SECOND PART WHICH WAS RECENTLY
AMENDED INTO THE BILL WOULD
GRANT A JOINT POWERS AUTHORITY
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA METROLINK.
AUTHORITY TO PURSUE CMG C.
CONTRACTING WITH THAT WE ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC THE LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT.
OF THE AUTHORS BILL [inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
SEMI ANXIOUSLY WAITING IN THE
BACK TO TESTIFY.
IN OPPOSITION TO THE AUTHORS
BILL [inaudible]
I'M.
PLEASE TAKE YOUR NAME AND HE
REPRESENTING PLEASE.
IF I MAY MISTER CHAIR JUST TO BE
CLEAR THAT I WAS TESTIFYING ON
BEHALF OF METROLINK.
IN THE SENSE THAT THAT'S SO THE
RECORD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MORE TALK ON BEHALF OF
THE ORANGE COUNTY TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY --
AND PAPA START OF COURSE BY A I
SINCERELY APOLOGIZING TO THE
COMMITTEE AND THE CHAIRMAN ARTS
HIS MAN [inaudible] TEN ON THE
FLIP SIDE --
OF OUR LATE OPPOSITION BUT WE'D
REALLY JUST BECAME AWARE OF THIS --
BELL WAS IT WAS A GOTTEN A MAN.
TIME ABOUT THREE O'CLOCK
YESTERDAY SO --
WE WE HAVE BEEN STARTING WE DO
HAVE SOME VERY SERIOUS CONCERNS --
BUT I I WOULD LIKE TO START BY
SAYING THAT SEEMED YOU SEE WE
SEE THEMES YOU SEE AS A AS A
VERY EFFECTIVE TOOL --
IT'S BEEN USED GIANT THROUGHOUT
THE STATE AND THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTRY AS AN EFFECTIVE TOOL TO
BRING PROJECTS --
TO COMPLETION QUICKLY AND AND ON
TIME AND AND ON BUDGET --
THERE IS SOMETHING HOWEVER
UNIQUE TO THIS PARTICULAR
AUTHORITY METROLINK IS AN
ORGANIZATION THAT SUCH A PA A
FORM FROM.
I MULTIPLE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
COUNTIES ORANGE COUNTY IS THE
SECOND LARGEST MEMBER.
OF METRO LINK --
AND WHAT'S UNIQUE FOR US IS THAT.
WE AN ORANGE COUNTY FOR PROJECTS
ON THE METROLINK LINE THAT
OPERATED ONE AND CONSTRUCTED
WITHIN.
THE COUNTY OF ORANGE.
WE ACTUALLY PERFORM THAT
CONSTRUCTION WORKER STOPS.
IT'S HISTORIC IT'S BEEN DONE
THIS WAY FOR THE LAST DECADE --
THERE'S KIND OF A WHOLE HOST OF%
HISTORY ON WHY THAT'S COME TO
PUT COME TO BE ONE OF THE
REASONS IS BECAUSE WE ACTUALLY
OWN.
ALL FORTY TWO MILES OF TRACK --
OF THE METROLINK LINE.
AND AND AND BECAUSE OF THAT WE
THINK THAT IT MAKES REALLY VERY
LITTLE SENSE TO PROVIDE THIS THE
MGC AUTHORITY.
FROM METRO LINK OUT WITHIN
ORANGE COUNTY'S BORDERS WE THINK
THERE COULD BE GREAT VALUE
PROVIDED TO IT.
SO WE WOULD ASK THE COMMITTEE I
AM AND THE AUTHOR TO CONSIDER AN
AMENDMENT THAT WOULD --
THAT WOULD KIND OF A WRECK
PRACTICES --
IS PERFORMED WITHIN THE
METROLINK ON ORANGE COUNTY LINES.
AND EITHER PROVIDE THAT
AUTHORITY TO ORANGE COUNTY --
CTA FOR TO SEE MGC OR JUST
PROVIDE THE AUTHORITY TO THE TO
THE TO THE OTHER MEMBER AGENCIES.
OTHER OPERATE OUTSIDE OF ORANGE
COUNTY AND AND SO SO THAT LINKS
UP WITH CURRENT PRACTICE SO
WITHOUT AGAIN MY APOLOGIES FOR
THAT FOR NOT HAVING A LETTER AND
AND KIND OF DOING THIS ON THE
FLY BUT THOSE ARE CONCERNS IN
THEIR VERY REAL BECAUSE OF THE
THE CURRENT --
WAY THAT FIVE THE JPA IT'S
STRUCTURED.
THANK YOU FOR THAT TERM.
ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
LIKE TO TESTIFYING OPPOSITION TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE CLAIRE.
ANY QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE
OF THE AUTHOR MISTER DALY
.
LITTLE PUNCHY AFTER FLOOR
SESSION --
WHERE THEY WORD WAS OCS IN THE
LOOP ON THE CHANGED ON THE
RECENT CHANGES TO THE BILL?
SOMEONE AROUND TOLD BY METROLINK
STAFF THAT.
THE BOARD MEMBERS WERE MADE
AWARE -- AYE
I WOULD POINT OUT THAT --
UNDER THIS BILL IT JUST
AUTHORIZES THE JP TO PURSUE THIS
IT DOESN'T SAY WHERE THEY'RE
GOING TO USE THE AUTHORITY AND
SINCE METROLINK IS A A HAS
OSHITA A AS ONE OF ITS VOTING
BOARD MEMBERS.
IT COULD AS OF VOTING BOARD
MEMBER HAVE INFLUENCE ON THE
DECISION ON EXACTLY WHERE IN THE
TERRITORY OF THIS CONTRACTING
METHOD IS UTILIZED [inaudible]
WOULDN'T THAT.
BE IN LINE WITH THE AMENDMENT
SUGGESTED BY OC TEARS
REPRESENTATIVE --
AND WE MIGHT THAT BE ACCEPTABLE
TO THE AUTHOR.
THE AMENDMENT LANGUAGE I MEAN TO
ME THAT I UNDERSTAND IT'S
PERMISSIVE AND ALLOWS THE
CONVERSATION TO HAPPEN --
I DON'T KNOW IF MAKING
EXPLICITLY.
PUTTING AN END MAKES THAT CHANGE
AND WE WOULD PROBABLY HAVE A
BETTER.
I'D HAVE TO GET MORE DIRECTION
FROM MY BOARD AT THIS POINT YOU
KNOW WE'VE BEEN ASKED TO CONNOR.
PURSUE THIS AUTHORITY GIVEN THE
SUBSTANTIAL AWARDTHAT STATE
PROVIDED TO METROLINK TO IMPROVE
SERVICE AND OPEN A BOTTLE NEXT
TO THE FIVE HUNDRED THIRTY EIGHT
WHILE TERRITORY.
NOW THAT NATURALLY CA CURRENTLY
OPERATES SERVICE AND I DON'T
THINK THE BILL MANDATES THIS TO
HAPPEN IT JUST ALLOWS IT TO
HAPPEN AND IT ALLOWS THE
PARTNERSHIP. TO DISCUSS WHERE
AND WHEN IT HAPPENS IT JUST
MAKES IT ELIGIBLE.
SO I DON'T THINK IT'S A FATE
ACCOMPLI SUCH I'M A LITTLE BIT
SURPRISED BY.
THE NEED FOR THE AMENDMENT BUT
THAT'S WELL I I SEE THE OF
AMENDMENT AS AS NOT CUMBERSOME
[inaudible] TO METROLINX
MISSION --
BUT I'M RESPECTFUL OF THE AUTHOR
AS WELL.
AND IF THE MEMBER IS NOT
ACCEPTABLE ABLE RESPECTFULLY
LAYOFFS THIS BILL TODAY.
GIVEN THAT MY HOME AREA --
BY HAS A PROBLEM.
THEN AGAIN I WOULD COMMIT TO
ENCOURAGING.
TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES TO HAVE
THIS CONVERSATION --
THIS AFTERNOON AND TRY TO FIGURE
IT OUT I MEAN I'M JUST NOT
PREPARED TO ACCEPT THE AMENDMENT
TODAY.
BUT I WILL CERTAINLY THAT SEEMS
LIKE A FAMILY SQUABBLE THAT
SHOULD BE.
WORKED OUT SINCE EVERYBODY HAS
THE SAME INTERESTS I THE I DON'T
SEE THERE BEING A PROBLEM DOWN
THE ROAD.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS MISTER
HARPER.
YEAH I I HAVE THE SAME CONCERNS
OF COURSE OUT REPRESENTING
ORANGE COUNTY IN BEING BOARD
MEMBER FOR A CT A ON MYSELF
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF WORK
THAT'S BEEN DONE IN TERMS OF
ACQUIRING RIGHT OF WAY.
I IS A SELF HELP COUNTY I MEAN
WE DEFINITELY I TAKE THAT --
RESPONSIBILITY AND THAT ROLE
VERY SERIOUSLY.
I IF YOU CAN JUST HELP HELP ME
UNDERSTAND BECAUSE THIS CAME
AROUND.
YOU JUST --
YESTERDAY I ENDO CTA HAD TO
REACT WITHIN A TWENTY FOUR HOUR
PERIOD I GUESS TO BE READY FOR
FOR THIS WHAT WHAT IS THE
URGENCY OF ADDING THIS INTO THIS
BILL THAT THAT'S ONE THING I
THINK IS REALLY IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND FROM THE AUTHORS.
WHY DID THIS COME DOWN AND WHY
ISN'T THERE TIME THAT THAT CAN
BE PROJECTED OUT NOR HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT THIS RATHER
THAN HASTILY ADOPTING THIS TOOK
A QUICK?
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF
FROM NETFLIX PERSPECTIVE NOW WE
RECEIVE THE LARGEST AWARD OF
FUNDING IN THE HISTORY OF THE
AGENCY.
AND ONCE --
WE EMBARK UPON IMPLEMENTING ALL
OF THE IMPROVEMENTS ACROSS THE
FIVE HUNDRED THIRTY EIGHT MILE
TERRITORY WE WHERE WE PROVIDE
SERVICES CRISSCROSSING THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA BASIN --
MASSIVE IMPROVEMENTS WE ARE
HOPING TO THE THIRTY AS EARLY AS
POSSIBLE SO WE CAN START THE
GAME PLAN TO DO THE SYSTEM WIDE
IMPROVEMENTS SO THAT.
ADD.
AT THE END OF THE GOAL WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE A FIFTEEN MINUTE
HEADWAYS.
AND OF THE CORE PART OF OUR
SERVICE AREA AND THEN THIRTY
MINUTE HEADWAYS IN THE
EXTREMITIES.
AND IT'S A BIG UNDERTAKING WE'VE
AWARDED A MERE BILLION DOLLARS
IT'S A VERY BIG PROJECT --
METROLINK IS USUALLY WORKING
WITH THEIR MEMBER AGENCIES TO
HAVE THEM TAKE THE LEAD ON
CONTRACTING THIS IS AN INSTANCE
WHERE WE'RE SEEKING TO BE THE
LEAD GIVEN THAT SYSTEM WIDE.
NOW THE LEVEL IMPROVEMENTS THAT
WE'RE PURSUING IT SO WE CAN
START EARLY ENOUGH FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE AND WE BELIEVE THIS
CONTRACTING APPROACH ALLOWS US.
TO BRING IN A CONSTRUCTION FIRM.
DURING THE DESIGN PHASE TO
ACTUALLY GAMEPLAN.
WHAT'S GOING TO BE A OF A VERY
COMPLEX PROJECT DELIVERY
TIMELINE WITH MULTIPLE MOVING
PARTS.
AND THAT'S WHY IF WE GET THE
CLARITY AND LAW THAT WE HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO PURSUE THIS.
A PROCUREMENT APPROACH WE CAN
ACTUALLY PLAY OUT THE TIME LINE
IN THE GAME PLAN FOR ALL THE
SEGMENTS OF OUR REGION TO MAKE
THESE IMPROVEMENTS WHAT WERE
ESSENTIALLY DOING IS OPENING UP.
BOTTLENECKS.
IN RAIL SERVICE SO THAT.
A DRIVERS WHO HAVE THE
ALTERNATIVE ON THOSE LONG
COMMUTES WHERE THAT WHEREVER THE
COMING FROM YOU KNOW VENTURA
RIVERSIDE.
HOWEVER THEIR DESTINATION THEY
CAN ACTUALLY.
RELY ON THE RAIL SERVICE.
THAT'S COMING ON FIFTEEN MINUTE
OR A THIRTY MINUTE HEADWAYS AND
IT'S A REAL ALTERNATIVE TO
DRIVING IN THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA BASIN.
BUT THOUGH THE CORE PART OF THE
RISK THERE ARE APPROACH IN OUR
DESIRE TO GET ISN'T ALREADY NOW
IS BECAUSE OF THE LEAD TIME THAT
IT TAKES. TO A PLAN AND EXECUTE
THIS KIND OF A SYSTEM WIDE
IMPROVEMENT.
WITH A VERY LARGE ARE REAL
AGENCY SO TO YOUR YOUR ANSWER
HELPS ME UNDERSTAND THE REASON
FAR PROVING IT DURING THIS
LEGISLATIVE SESSION.
AYE BUT WHAT I DON'T UNDERSTAND
IS WHY THE LANGUAGE WAS
INTRODUCED JUST ABOUT A COUPLE
DAYS OUTSIDE A WEEK OF THE
LEGISLATIVE --
CLOSED ARE DEADLINE SO WE GOT
THE AWARD --
FROM CAO STA IN APRIL --
WE'VE BEEN WORKING TO DEVELOP A
GAME PLAN WE ACTUALLY HIRED.
AN ENGINEERING STAFF FOLKS WITH
PUBLIC WORKS EXPERTISE AT THE
BILL THE BRAIN TRUST WITH AT
METROLINK TO COME A DEVELOPER
GAME PLAN.
AND THEN WE GOT THE
RECOMMENDATION FROM STAFF TO
PURSUE CNPC AUTHORITY AS
SOMETHING THAT COULD BRING HIM
BACK TEAM BASED APPROACH A
COLLABORATION ON THE FRONT.
AFFORD DESIGNS COMPLETED --
WHAT WE GOT THAT ALREADY WERE
AWARE THAT THE RECOMMENDATION
WAS MADE WE'RE KIND FROM RECESS
AND HERE WE ARE?
FEW WEEKS BACK FROM SUMMER
RECESS THERE'S ONLY FOUR WEEKS
AGO.
SESSION AND AND IT WAS IMPORTANT
OF A FOREIGN US TO TRY THIS NOW
SO THAT WE CAN GET AHEAD OF THIS
VERY MASSIVE SET OF PUBLIC WORKS
IMPROVEMENTS THROUGHOUT OUR
SYSTEM.
IF I CAN ASK IT LOOKS LIKE YOU
HAVE A REACTION TO THAT.
THANK YOU --
TO THE CHAIR --
WE IT THAT'S ACTUALLY
UNPRECEDENTED TO PROVIDES TMCC
AUTHORITY BEFORE --
ANY ENVIRONMENTAL BY DOCUMENTS
HAVE HAVE EVEN BEGUN ON THESE
PROJECTS TO THE EXTENT THAT WE
KNOW ABOUT ANY OF THE PROJECT
AND TO BE PERFECTLY FRANK NOT.
TO TALK ABOUT A FAMILY SQUABBLE
BUT I THINK THAT THAT'S A LITTLE
BIT OF WHAT YOU'RE SEEING HERE.
IS THAT WE MEMBER OF THE MEMBER
AGENCIES ARE NOT FULLY AWARE OF
THE FOR THE FULL COMPLEXITY OF
IT IS A IT IS AN AGGRESSIVE
PROJECT WE'RE EXCITED ABOUT IT
BUT WE DON'T KNOW MUCH ABOUT IT.
AND IT IS OUR BOARDS THAT WILL
BE [inaudible]
STOVER RUNS.
ANY OTHER KINDS OF CHALLENGES
AND PROBLEMS WITH THE PROJECT.
AND SO --
BECAUSE THERE HAVEN'T BEEN
ENVIRONMENTAL DOCUMENTS EVEN BUT
DON ON THESE PROJECTS WE THINK
IT IS PREMATURE TO OUGHT TO BE
PROVIDING --
THE AUTHORITY --
IN A BLANKET WAY AND LETS YOU
KNOW WHAT WE THINK IT WOULD MAKE
A LOT MORE SENSE TO BE FIGURING
OUT WHERE THESE PROJECTS ARE WHO
HAS OWNERSHIP.
AND AND AND HOW TO MAKE CMG
STATE CMG SEE REALLY WORK
PROPERLY THERE'S NO RUSH RIGHT
NOW TO DO IT.
THE PROJECT THAT WE'RE AWARE OF
HAVEN'T EVEN BEGUN THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR FOR THOSE CONCERNS
ON I WOULD BE IN OPPOSITION BE
VERY SYMPATHETIC TO THE OF CT A
POSITION AT THIS POINT.
THAT IS YOUR A BILLION IS SO.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS SCRIPT THIS
IS BAKER.
THANK YOU AND I AM I'M JUST
NOTICING TWO MEMBERS FROM AN
AREA GREATLY AFFECTED BY THE
BILL.
BOTH PARTIES AND AND WONDERING
IF I IF I A JEW DEL BRIEFLY IF
IF THERE IS AN AGREEMENT
[inaudible] TO TO CONSIDER
TAKING AMENDMENTS BEFORE WE
MIGHT SEE THIS AGAIN OF IS THAT
I WOULD I JUST WOULD LIKE TO
CLARIFY.
OUT OF RESPECT FOR TO COLLEAGUES.
CHALLENGES THE DEADLINE
[inaudible]
I'M.
PERFECTLY OPEN TO PURSUING A
CONVERSATION I LEAVE IT IS A
FAMILY SQUABBLE THAT CAN BE
WORKED OUT.
I JUST DON'T KNOW.
TECHNICALLY IF WE HAVE THE
ABILITY TO DO THAT --
AND I HATE TO HAVE THE DEFERRED
RELATED PIECE OF THE STALLED.
BECAUSE I THINK THAT SAVES LIVES --
AND OBVIOUSLY WE DIDN'T
ANTICIPATE THAT THIS FAMILY
SQUABBLE WOULD.
HOW MEANT TO HAPPEN MINUTE YOU
VERY DIFFERENT COMPLETELY
ANALYZE IT FIRST VISIONS OF THE
BELLS SOMETIMES IT YEAH
THANKSGIVING AT LOCAL
[inaudible] TO A SQUABBLE THAT
YOU DON'T KNOW OVER THE TRUMPS
THAT --
THINK THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE HERE I
HAVE FAITH THAT THE WORK IT OUT
SINCE THEY SIT ON EACH OTHER'S
BOARDS AND HAVE CROSS
POLLINATION ENOUGH.
I'M A LITTLE BIT.
STRETCH THAT IT OKAY WASN'T AS
NEATLY TIED UP.
AS IT SHOULD HAVE BEEN.
BUT I JUST YOU KNOW I'M BEING
HONEST WITH YOU I DON'T KNOW
PROCEDURALLY WHAT WE CAN DO AT
THIS POINT BECAUSE I DON'T WANT
TO LOSE THE VEIL.
AND YOU KNOW I THINK THE FAMILY
WILL BE ABLE TO WORK IT OUT.
WELL I APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU
AT AN HONEST YES.
THANK YOU AND I I SUPPOSE I
WOULD THROUGHOUT THEIR IF IT'S
IF IT'S STILL BEING WORKED ON
THERE ARE OTHER THERE'S NOTHING.
TO ON THE DIFFERENT EARLIER PART
WHICH IS A CONCERN THAT YOU WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT HAPPENS TO
POINTS.
THERE'S NOTHING TO STOP THEM
FROM GETTING ONE NOW WHILE THE
FAMILY SQUABBLE WORKS OUT IS
THAT RIGHT LIKE THERE'S NOTHING
THAT'S SAYING YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED
TO HAVE THIS.
THAT THEY CAN'T GO FORWARD AND
DO IT.
KNOWING THAT THERE'S STILL SOME
WORK GOING ON THERE ISN'T A
BARRIER THAT YOU'RE REMOVING IN
THE BILL. TO THAT IS THAT
CORRECT. FOR POLITICAL CORRECT
[inaudible]
WERE [inaudible]
IN ESSENCE [inaudible]
MANDATING.
ARE BLAKE I MEAN WERE THERE NOT
RIGHT NOW THEY'RE NOT PREVENTED
FROM HAVING THEM IN A WHILE THIS
WORKS OUT ON AND AGENCIES.
GOD I JUST WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT
THE ANY OTHER PROVISION IS.
IN MY EXPERIENCE IN WORKING AND
SCHOOL SAFETY COMMITTEES INSIGHT
COUNCIL OTHERWISE WHEN WE
COULDN'T AFFORD IF THE COST OF A
DIFFERENT BILL LATER WAS
PROHIBITED.
YOU CAN GET A ONE TIME USE.
YOU CAN GET A ONE TIME USE
DEFIBRILLATOR THAT'S
DRAMATICALLY LESS EXPENSIVE THAT
MIGHT EVEN BE A PATCH DOES THIS.
BUT I THINK IT'S I I KNOW I
UNDERSTAND SOME WILLING TO WAIT
[inaudible]
YEAH.
IF YOU CAN ACTUALLY.
HOLD ON JUST A SECOND YEAH --
AS FOR OPOSSUM IT IS.
IN MY EXPERIENCE THAT NOT ONLY
ARE WE THERE'S NOTHING TO KEEP
THEM FROM MOVING FORWARD AGAIN
THE DEFENDER LATER WHICH IS A
REASON.
TO KIND OF PUSH FOR THE BELL AND
ONE TIME USE DEFIBRILLATORS.
ARE MUCH LESS EXPENSIVE SHOULD
THERE NEED TO BE AN EMERGENCY
KIND OF PATCH LIKE LET'S TRY TO
DO THIS I EXPERIENCE THAT IN
SCHOOL DISTRICT SYSTEMS.
IS THERE ANYTHING IN THE BILL
THAT [inaudible]
IT.
I WANNA MAKE SURE THAT THAT
WOULD COUNT IN THE MEANTIME THAT
THESE CAN THERE'S NOTHING THE
BILL THAT KEEPS IT FROM BEING A
ONE TIME USED TO FAVOR LATER.
THAT WHEN YOU'RE PUTTING THIS
REQUIREMENT IN THERE YOU'RE NOT.
PROHIBITING THAT IT CAN BE A ONE
TIME USE AND THESE GUYS CAN GO
FORWARD AND START WORKING ON THE
OTHER FAMILY SQUABBLE.
I BELIEVE THAT'S OKAY.
I'M I JUST WANNA LAY OFF OUT OF
SURELY RESPECT YOU AND AND TRIED
TO ADDRESS IMPORTANT ISSUE.
AND SEVEN I WOULD OTHERWISE
SUPPORT BUT MEMBERS IN THIS BODY
IN THIS COMMITTEE HARM.
BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE WHO WERE
IN THE JURISDICTION MOST
AFFECTED BY IT KNOWING THAT
THERE'S NOTHING TO STOP
DEFIBRILLATORS FROM GETTING ON
THESE TRAINS RIGHT NOW
ESPECIALLY IF YOU GET A ONE TIME
USE THAT'S A LOT LESS EXPENSIVE.
US SO THANK YOU FOR CLARIFYING
THAT.
TALKING TO BOTH SIDES THEY BOTH
SAID THAT THEY BELIEVE IF THEY
COULD WORK OUT THE FAMILY
SQUABBLE BY FRIDAY.
BY NEXT FIRE DEADLINE I MEAN.
I'M OPERATING ON GOOD FAITH WITH
THEM -- SO
MY UNDERSTANDING IS IF I MAY
MISTER CHAIR CAN YOU WORK IT
THIS OUT BY NEXT WEEK --
MEAN YOU GUYS THAT SOUNDS LIKE
THE VOTES AREN'T HERE SO IT JUST
SEEMS TO ME LIKE YOU GUYS SHOULD
WORK IT OUT.
IT'S SUPPORT RECOMMENDATION EVEN
IN LIGHT OF THE LATE.
OPPOSITION WHICH WAS I THINK
UNFAIR AT THIS POINT --
BUT I WILL TELL YOU THAT WE CAN
HOLD IT OVER [inaudible]
AND WE WILL WE WILL GO AHEAD
[inaudible]
MY VIEW.
SO I WILL TELL YOU WHAT THAT
FOLLOW THE CHAIRS [inaudible]
IN ADDITION.
WE CAN HOLD THAT OVER AND YOU
CAN COME INTO NEXT WEEK.
GIVE A CHANCE.
YOU HAVE YOU MAKE THE CALL.
RIGHT NOW YOU HAVE A CHAIRS
RECCO ALRIGHT THEN LET'S TAKE A
VOTE.
THE CHAIR'S RECOMMENDING AND I
I'M HOPING.
COLLEAGUES WILL HELP ME GET IT
OUT AND I'M HOPING THESE TWO
WILL SHOW GOOD FAITH AND WORK IT
OUT.
THAT'LL BE MY CLOTHES THANK YOU --
SO ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THAT.
ARE OF THE COMMITTEE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS.
WE HAVE THEM BILLION YOUR THIRD
MISTER [inaudible]
KANSEN CHU --
SO WITH THAT HOME.
IT'S PORTANTINO WE HAVE OUR
FIRST WITNESS FRIEDMAN SECOND
WITH MR MEDINA --
ONE THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD.
I HAVE ABSOLUTE FAITH THAT THESE
TWO INDIVIDUALS WILL BE ABLE TO
WORK OUT TO A SOLUTION.
THAT WORKS TO ADDRESS THE
CONCERNS OF THE ORANGE COUNTY
MEMBERS.
OF THIS COMMITTEE.
AND BUT I I'M A VERY BIG
PROPONENT FOR CMC.
AGING HAVE BEEN FOREVER AS A
GENERAL CONTRACTOR IT'S
ESSENTIAL.
BUT YOU HAVE THIS ABILITY TO
MAKE SURE THESE PROJECTS ARE
COST EFFECTIVE.
THAT'S WHY I'M SUPPORTING THIS I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL
TRANSPORTATION MONIES ARE
UTILIZED TO THE BEST
[inaudible]
VALUE.
SO THAT'S WHY WE'RE GONNA MOVE
FOR WITH THIS.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE KALRA.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS FRAZIER
AYE FRAZIER AYE FONG.
FONG NOT LETTING AGUIAR-CURRY.
I AGUIAR-CURRY I BAKER.
BAKER NOT VOTING BERMAN
[inaudible]
CHIU.
CHIU AYE DALY.
DALY NOT VOTING FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN AYE GIPSON OR GIPSON
AYE HARPER.
HARPER NO MATHIS.
MATHIS NOT VOTING MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE AS AREA.
NAZARIAN AYE O'DONNELL
[inaudible]
O'DONNELL I YOU HAVE EIGHT YOUR
HELP THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THINKING MEMBERS THANK YOU WAS
PORTANTINO --
MAN PREVIEW COAL --
CALLED FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS ON
THAT AND FALL WITH THE CALL ON
THE ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
CURRENT VOTE IS. NINE TO ZERO
BAKER.
BAKER AYE BERMAN [inaudible]
CHIU [inaudible]
CHIU AYE [inaudible]
NAZARIAN [inaudible]
NAZARIAN AYE.
ON THE CAN THANK OUR O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL AYE.
CURRENT WROTE.
THIRTEEN TO ZERO FILE ITEM TO
ACR TWO SEVENTY SIX CURRENT VOTE
IS ELEVEN TO ZERO BAKER.
BAKER AYE BERMAN [inaudible]
NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN AYE CURRENT VOTE
.
THIRTEEN TO ZERO FILE ITEM SEVEN
AB.
EIGHTY SEVEN CURRENT VOTE IS
ELEVEN TO ZERO BAKER.
BAKER AYE BERMAN [inaudible]
NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN AYE CURRENT VOTE THE
THIRTEEN TO ZERO FILE ITEM EIGHT
CURRENT VOTE IS TEND TO ZERO
BAKER.
BAKER AYE BERMAN [inaudible]
NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN AYE CURRENT VOTE.
TWELVE TO ZERO FILE ITEM TEN S.
B. FIVE OH TO CURRENT VOTE IS IT.
TO ZERO FINAL VOTE IT TO THEIR
OF VOTE IF OF FONG VOTE CHANGED
I FILE ITEM TEN SP FIVE A TO
VOTE CHANGE FONG NOT VOTING TO
AYE.
FINAL VOTE.
NINE TO ONE SORT OF VISUAL
ADDRESS CAN.
A YES BUT CHAIRMAN FRASER OF HER
SMALL AYE I WANT TO APPRECIATE I
UNDERSTAND THE BILLS HAVE BEEN
PULLED WELL LET ME ENTER ODD YOU
KNOW.
MY OBJECTION TOO NOT BEING
NOTIFIED BEFORE I WAS SITTING IN
THE FRONT ROW OF THIS COMMITTEE.
THESE PARTICULAR BILLS ONE HAVE
TO DO WITH WITH A FIREFIGHTER
WHO IS KILLED AYE IN THE LINE OF
DUTY.
WE HAVE A CALL OUT THERE.
US SENATOR LARA AND EXPECTED TO
BE ABLE 2% TODAY.
HA HITS VERY CURIOUS THAT THE
BILL HAS BEEN THAT BILL HAS BEEN
CALLED.
UPON AT THE DMV BILL WE KNOW
THAT THROUGHOUT THIS STATE WE
HAVE MAJOR PROBLEMS IN OUR D. M.
V. OFFICE.
AND WITHOUT ANY EXPLANATION AND
CERTAINLY TAKING MUCH TIMELINE
PART OF YOUR STAFF AND YOURSELF.
A TO A MANDATE SO THAT IT WAS
ACCEPTABLE FOGEL A FORWARD TO
THIS COMMITTEE HAS BEEN PULLED
WITH NO EXPLANATION.
SO FOR JUST ON BEHALF OF MYSELF
MY CAUCUS AND THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
AFFECTED BY THIS BILL IT WOULD
BE VERY VERY IMPORTANT TO GET A
FULL EXPLANATION.
OF WHY SOMETHING IS PRECEDENT
SETTING TO POLYBIA WHEN A
SENATORS SITTING IN THE FRONT
ROW READY 2% AND HAS NOT BEEN
INFORMED BEFORE I CAME OVER HERE.
ONTO BILL SORT OF FACT
SIGNIFICANT POPULATIONS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND A FAMILY
WHO SUFFERED.
DRAMATICALLY THE LOSS OF THEIR
FATHER AND THEIR MAJOR WAGE
EARNER INTO THIS STATE A
FIREFIGHTER WHO IS PROTECTING
ALL OF US.
THANK YOU SENATOR BATES YOUR
BILLS OF EMPLOYMENT REQUESTED TO
SPEAK [inaudible]
MOST ADVERTISEMENT MANAGEMENT
COMMON.
I'M ACTUALLY SURPRISED TO THOSE
BILLS FULLER IS READY TO HEAR
TODAY.
I ACTUALLY ATTENDED THE FUNERAL.
OF THIS VERY DEDICATED
FIREFIGHTER VERY DEDICATED THE
CITY LONG BEACH GREW UP.
MUCH OF HIS LIFE IN LONG BEACH
HIS PARENTS ON LONG BEACH IT
DOWN IN YOUR DISTRICT NOW HE HE
WHERE HE RESIDED WITH THIS
FAMILY.
THIS LOVELY WIFE IS TO CHILDREN
ONE OF THEM SIXTEEN YEARS OLD IN
HIGH SCHOOL SO.
SO I'M SADDENED HERE THAT WAS
THIS WAS POOR.
I WAS EXPECTING HER AS YOU SAT
HERE I DID NOT KNOW.
PULLED SO --
I HOPE WE CAN GET THIS.
HANDLED EXPEDITIOUSLY IN A
WITHOUT OF DISCONTENT.
A LEVER THAT MISTER CHAIR BUT I
JUST THIS IS A GOOD MAN.
THAT DESERVES OUR RESPECT AND
DESERVES TO BE RESPECTED
EVERYDAY THIS PEOPLE DRIVING ON
THE FREEWAY AND SEE HIS NAME.
AND RECOGNIZE THAT HE GAVE HIS
LIFE IN THE LINE OF DUTY --
FOR THE CITIZENS OF LONG BEACH.
AS A MEMBER WHO MENTIONED THE
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE REQUESTS IN
THE BILL'S PEOPLE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER [inaudible]
THAT WILL.
DELTA CHAIRMAN I MOVE TO HEAR
THE BILL THAT SENATOR BATES JUST
PUT FORWARD SECTOR THE COURTESY
THAT SHE'S HERE MAILING LIST
HERE.
WE WE WE CAN THINK OF HOLLOW
MISTER CHAIRMAN THERE'S A MOTION
ON THE FLOOR IT'S BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED AND ENTERTAINING
EMOTION WITH THE BULLET.
BILL HAD BEEN POLLS.
WITH NO CARE THE BODY.
THE OF IT YOU MEAN IT IS IT
POSSIBLE THAT THESE BILLS BE
HEARD NEXT WEEK AND NEXT HEARING
THERE IS A VERY GOOD POSSIBILITY
THAT BILL CAN BE HEARD NEXT WEEK
AND THE RESOLUTION.
I APPRECIATE THAT THIS CHAIRMAN